comme Health Month (le mois de la santé) pour les gens.
Et pourquoi construit-il un truc pareil?
Bien, voici l'ensemble des axiomes
que Habit Labs, la compagnie de Buster, a établi pour eux-mêmes
sur la façon dont ils voulaient travailler en équipe
quand ils construisent ces applications,
un ensemble de principes moraux qu'ils se fixent
pour travailler ensemble,
et l'un d'eux étant,
« Nous prenons soin de notre propre santé et gérons notre propre épuisement. »
Parce qu'en fin de compte, comment pouvez-vous vous poser la question à vous-même
et comment pouvez-vous trouver une réponse
quant à quelle vision de la belle vie
vous voulez transmettre et créer avec vos conceptions
sans poser la question,
quelle vision de la belle vie
voulez-vous vivre vous-même ?
Et sur ce, je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)